I walked into the room and I felt it was  a little tense like we were really far  away from them and that kind of felt  awkward there was a couple of moments  where there was some silence and it made  it hard to break the ice and I'm moving  to the dinner table it was just a  different vibe in the room maybe they're  trying to figure me out and I don't know  have you ever known anybody in a  military family before no it was my  first my first is my first day so tell  me what do you see in Lauren that might  be different um I've always just been  really drawn to her when are you gonna  be ready to settle down are you there  yes  [Music]  and he stepped out real quick I'll be  right back  kind of freaking out the biggest race  ever competed in was the Indy 500 and  nerves were at a 10 that be maximum and  I'm approaching that  you